hey what's up gq i'm tanner buchanan and
today i'm going undercover on the
interwebs
it's actually me
is interwebs too weird or do you want me
to say internet
[Music]
oh oh what do we have from twitter
tanner buchanan how is it being to work
alongside addison you learned or taught
more it was amazing to work with addison
she worked really hard came in and you
would never know that she hadn't acted
before i'm always learning from
everybody doesn't matter who it is
so i'd say to give and take i would say
50 50.
this one is how was the kiss referring
to the mtv awards it was great you know
we uh tried to shock some of the viewers
seemed to work i mean that's what a lot
of people were talking about for a few
days
how is tanner buchanan not related to
val kilmer or the sprouse twins
i've never heard the sprouts twins
before i have gotten before that i look
like a younger val kilmer which i will
completely take he is an actor that i
look up to and i think he has amazing
performances i'd love to play younger
val kilmer or maybe his son or something
maybe if they make a top gun 3 or if
they remake tombstone that would be
awesome i'll be your huckleberry
cora
[Music]
i think of avatar the last airbender
when i think of that does tanner
buchanan have a girlfriend yes i do her
name is elizabeth broadway most people
know her as lizzie broadway and she's
absolutely wonderful
who are the strongest cobra kai
characters ranked oh
that one's really hard i'll do top three
i would have to say
crease is number three mostly because
he's a little bit older than all the
other actors i'm gonna give number two
to ralph macchio who plays daniel and
the only reason i'm i'm putting billy
zabka at number one who plays johnny is
just because he plays my dad on the show
and i i gotta give him number one
how do martial arts instructors
students feel about netflix's cobra kai
so i've been approached by a lot of
people that practice martial arts and a
lot of them are extremely happy that
martial arts is getting back out there
i've talked to a lot of parents and kids
who have started martial arts because of
the show which is actually really cool
knowing that we influence that the
martial arts world is getting more
notice that's actually a really nice
question
should warner bros and dc consider cobra
kai actor tanner buchanan for a future
role as a young batman i'm going to be
honest i don't care what superhero i get
to play or whatever it might be marvel
dc i want to play superhero just please
let me be in something i just i just
want to play a superhero that's that's
all i've ever wanted since i've been a
young kid is to play a superhero
right now we got reddit
you may not believe it but it's actually
me had he ever seen any of the karate
kid films before getting the role if yes
when did he first see them i had seen
the first one around five years old my
mom was actually a black belt in karate
in the 80s and she actually introduced
it to me next we have which dojo would
he prefer to join in real life who
amongst all the young cobra kai miyagido
actors has become the best martial
artist if there was any dojo i wanted to
join in real life probably say cobra kai
just because they're the most ruthless
and badass out of the bunch who amongst
all the young cobra kai miyagido actors
has become the best i'm gonna give this
one to mary mary mauser who plays
samantha she's really improved a lot
over the past few years and is
absolutely killing it many people online
have said that tanner resembles 90s era
hot throbs hot frogs heartthrobs such as
ryder strong and jonathan brandis does
tanner see a resemblance between himself
and either writer or jonathan why or why
not i don't know if i see it myself i've
seen a lot of a lot of posts that have
put pictures next to either writer or
jonathan i guess i just kind of have
that that 90s look sure i i'll say i do
anybody think that tanner buchanan from
cobra kai could play a younger anakin
skywalker in the future i would love to
be in the star wars universe i don't
know how many more movies that they
would even want to make in the future
but sure
i'll take it
next
back to twitter
hey tanner did you have a good christmas
yes i did have a good christmas so i
read that you already studied tarquando
and muay thai but did you also have to
learn karate or another martial arts for
robbie and cobra kai yes i did know
tarquando i took that for a little bit
when i was about 10 or 11 years old and
then trained in muay thai for about
eight months before i started cobra kai
but our stunt coordinators and fight
coordinator are kind of in charge of the
martial arts that we do and we we do a
whole mix of stuff some taekwondo and
some muay thai all kinds of stuff going
on there what was working with
kieran sutherland like i think they mean
kiefer sutherland kiefer was great most
people might or might not know kiefer is
actually a musician so most of the days
were filled with us if we weren't doing
a scene we would actually go out to his
trailer and play guitar together and he
would sing so you know a lot of good
memories there
tanner buchanan are participating in
season four of cobra kai or not because
she is making the film she all that i am
in season four he's all that actually
shot a few months before we started
shooting season four i guess you'll have
to see what goes on in that season
hey bro are you from lima ohio i was
born in lima ohio however i'm from a
smaller town about 20 miles from there
called ottawa ohio just mostly farmers
very very small town
we nailed it
wikipedia
in 2010 he made his first appearance on
television playing a child role in the
modern family series yes that is true i
played kid number two in the halloween
episode and i was a mummy i had one line
i can see his feet i think
what i remember is i didn't have a clue
going on i just knew i had to come in
and save my line i just couldn't screw
that up
i painted a picture of a butterfly
you're quoting something aren't you yes
i was so i've found a liking to twitter
to almost just comment with the most
obscure kind of tweets to put out there
most of them are quotes and this was
actually december 29th i had just
watched elf which is one of my favorite
movies i was just quoting will ferrell
there
thanks to everybody for the questions
but uh i think i'm gonna sign off the
interwebs for now see ya